it is so important and moments like this
that we stand United and we do stand
here United as one voice in our
condemnation against this horrific
attack on a police officer someone who's
part of our community and I think that
the most powerful message that we as
political leaders can start can do is to
stand with the chief Constable today at
a stand with the police service and to
say this is not good enough this is an
attack on all of us this is an attack on
our community and finally the only other
thing that I would want to say today is
that my thoughts very much remain with
the family these are this is a family
who are going through a trauma these are
a family that are sitting at a hospital
bed this is a son who's witnessed his
father being attacked in this callous
way so my thoughts are very very much
with John's family today